[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission où ça découvre la
Réunion vous allez réparer alors
allons-nous
[Musique]
au singulier dans la commune de
Saint-André plus précisément sur le
parking de la forêt durée et ben nous
nous a fait la petite boucle pour
découle la forêt du orée et nous on va
aller
par là allez et ballons-nous quand on
était coincé en France rien que ça même
moi
tes pommes retrouve mon moment rien que
la même mon regard des danses derrière
Elena la montagne
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour comment allez-vous en
plus
carré dans la forêt durer bah oui bah
très agréable aujourd'hui il fait beau
voilà ça fait plus d'une semaine qu'il
pleuvait donc ça fait du bien de
retrouver un peu de soleil d'accord et
on en profite des vacances pour faire
sortir un peu les enfants et le chien et
en terme de randonnée mais voilà en
famille est-ce que elle est vraiment
pratique pour les enfants oui il y a pas
trop de dénivelé d'accord le chemin est
très large et donc du coup c'est
vraiment bien c'est entretenu par une
association d'en haut là ok
l'association fait très beau travail
d'accord et où là par la moyenne
vacances vient est-ce que l'important
c'est moi dans la forêt pour bannette
découvre un peu scolaire elle est très
important de quitter un peu les écrans
d'accord que les quelque chose de
primordial d'accord
bonjour monsieur comment
tous les arbres et 8 d'accord
à cause du travail au travail sur le
site là oui de ça fait 12 ans combien
là-dessus d'accord
mais entretien le site de A à
z252 cas 252
fait une forêt
tu commences un peu être dangereux quand
même mais ça vaut une pizza
donc là vous avez tout droit tout droit
la leçon
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène parle pas nous aller nous verrez
la même un peu de respect pour mon pays
vraiment d'après depuis son lit au bout
de la terre dans le paradis pour
comprendre mon pays
la réunion nous les la même mon pays
comment il est la Réunion
s'amène alors du coup bah il pense que
la arrive à la fin du sentier un joli
petit kiosque en plus ton bien
en forme
alors du coup
de la randonnée du coup alors là il fait
un bon moment tu es pas encore fait
une remise en marche comédie
alors mais je suppose que ça va
le petit village de ça l'Asie et après
au loin un petit peu elle va la vue il
est magnifique et surtout quand c'est
bien dégagé là c'est top quoi la
récompense le top des tops en tout cas
tes amis
le point de vue ah ok bah en tout cas
elle est magnifique ben écoute ça ne
peut même tu peux la cascade blanche 640
m
ici à nous laisser le toit de la Réunion
en bas et ici
elle est vraiment magnifique la petite
balade il vaut vraiment le coup d'œil et
ben nous on va faire le retour par la
boucle allez et ben nous ça va
OK et ben voilà nous la fait la petite
boucle alors faudra faire attention
parce que de temps en temps les glissons
parce que Nana la boue alors durée
oublie pas que Diori nous laisse sur un
ens que ça allait un ens un espace
naturel sensible nous voit déjà que
c'est une protection pour que la faune
et la flore ils sont en zone bien dans
un milieu naturel alors Ben qui ça a été
durer durer l'été un ancien gouverneur
il la mette en place le développement du
café et grâce à l'île la connu un essor
économique et c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
la forêt il porte son nom et ben nous
nous on va retrouve notre point de
départ que la planète est fait la boucle
alors bah du coup nous la arrive au
point de départ et nous ça avoir la
pépinière dont Robert la part la nous
par ici allez et ben nous ça va barreau
les rouvert on va rentrer monsieur
comment allez là alors
ici il arrive il prend de l'autre côté
voilà ici si c'est l'endroit où ça nous
produit d'accord ne faisait semi nous
remettre en sachet et après nous
remettre la bosse à obéon dans la zone
de restauration d'accord
2000 3000 plans par an boîte cabri
d'accord
ne peut retrouver aussi Mao et après le
plus souvent ça nous retrouve sur ce
chantier c'est bois de pomme d'accord et
aujourd'hui au travail ici tout ça
est-ce que le plus fier
des gens protègent notre forêt dernier
forêt bois de couler cet André reste
c'est ça donc du coup c'est un fierté
c'est vrai encore
de la forêt durée tu es bien gaillard en
tout cas la réunion n'a gagné
et pour ça rendez vous la prochaine
épisode de l'émission allons-nous cette
fois-ci il sera dans la commune de
Saint-Louis nous sera au Mac derrière la
semaine on la trouve
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]